where we left off in the last video I
kind of gave you a question find an
interval so whether we're reasonably
confident we'll talk a little bit more
about what to give this kind of kind of
vague wording right here reasonably
confident there's a 95% chance the true
the true population mean the true
population mean which is P which is same
thing as the mean of the sampling
distribution of the sampling mean so
there's a 95% chance that the true mean
and let me put this here this is also
the same thing as the mean of the
sampling distribution of the sampling
mean is in that interval and to do that
let me just throw out a few ideas what
is the probability what is the
probability the probability that if I
take a if I take a sample and I were to
take a mean of that sample so if I the
probability that a random sample mean is
within is within two standard deviations
of the sampling mean of our sample mean
so what is this probability right over
here so let's just look at our actual
distribution so this is our distribution
this right here is our sampling mean
maybe I should do it in blue because
that's the number up here that it that's
the color up here this is our sampling
mean and so what is the probability that
a random sampling mean is going to be in
two standard deviations well a random
sampling mean is a sample from this
distribution it is a sample from the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
so it's literally what is the
probability of finding a sample within
two standard deviations of the mean
that's one standard deviation that's
another standard deviation right over
there and in general if you haven't
committed this to memory already it's
not a bad thing to commit to memory is
that if you have a normal distribution
the probability of taking a sample
within two standard deviations is ninety
five and if you want to get a little bit
a little bit more accurate it's ninety
five point four percent but you could
say it's roughly it's roughly or maybe I
could write this it's roughly 95 percent
and really that's all that matters
because we have this little funny
language here called reasonably
confident and we have to estimate the
standard deviation any
in fact we could say if we want I could
say that's going to be exactly equal to
ninety five point four percent but in
general two standard deviations ninety
five percent that's what people equate
with each other now this statement is
the exact same thing as the probability
that the sample mean that the sampling
mean or the the mean of the sample not
the sample mean the probability of the
mean of the sampling distribution is
within is within two standard deviations
of the sampling distribution of X is
also going to be the same number is also
going to be equal to ninety five point
four percent these are the exact same
statement if X is within two standard
deviations of this then this then the
mean is within two standard deviations
of X these are just two ways of phrasing
the same thing now we know that the set
the mean of the sampling distribution is
same as the same thing as the mean of
the population distribution which is the
same thing as the parameter P the
proportion of people who or the
proportion of the population that is a1
so this right here is the same thing as
the population mean so this statement
right here we can switch this with P so
the probably probability probability
that P is within two standard deviations
of the sampling distribution of X is
ninety five point four percent now we
don't know what this number right here
is but we have estimated it remember our
best estimate of this is the true
standard or it is the true standard
deviation of the population divided by
ten we can estimate the true standard
deviation of the population with our
sampling standard deviation which was
0.5 0.5 divided by 10 our best estimate
of the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
is point zero five so now we can say and
I'll switch colors the probability that
the parameter P the proportion of the
population saying one is within is
within two times
remember our best estimate of this right
here is 0.05 of
a sample mean that we take is equal to
95.4% and so we could say the
probability probability that P is within
2 times 0.05 is going to be equal to 2
point 0 is going to be zero point 100 of
our mean is equal to 95 well and
actually let me be a little careful here
I can't say the equal now because over
here if we knew this if we knew this
parameter of the sampling distribution
of the sample mean we could say that it
is 95.4% we don't know it we are just
trying to find our best estimator for it
so actually what I'm going to do here is
actually just say is roughly and I'm
just to show that we don't even have
that level of accuracy I'm going to say
roughly 95 percent we're reasonably
confident that it's about 95 percent
because we're using this estimator that
came out of our sample and if the sample
is really skewed this is going to be a
really weird number so this is why we
just have to be a little bit more exact
about what we're doing but this is a
tool for at least saying how good is our
result and so this is going to be about
95 percent or we could say that the
probability the probability that P is
within is within 0.10 of our sample mean
that we actually got so what was the
sample mean that we actually got it was
0.4 3 so if we're within 0.1 of 0.4 3
that means we are within 0.4 3 plus or
minus 0.1 plus or minus 0.1 is also
roughly where reasonably confident about
95% and I want to be very clear
everything that I started all the way
from pure and brown to yellow to all
this magenta I'm just restating the same
thing inside of this it became a little
bit more loosey-goosey once I went from
the exact standard deviation of the
sampling distribution to an estimator
for it and that's why this is just
becoming you know I kind of put the
squiggly equal signs there to say this
is we're reasonably confident I even got
rid rid of some of the precision but we
just found our interval an interval that
we can be reasonably confident that
there's a 95% problem
the D that P is within that is going to
be 0.4 3 plus or minus 0.1 or an
interval of we have a confidence
interval we have a 95% confidence
interval confidence interval interval of
and we could say 0.4 3 minus 0.1 minus
0.1 is 0.33 if we write that as a
percent we could say 33% 2 and if we add
the point 1 point 4 3 plus 0.1 we get 53
percent to 53 percent so we are 95%
confident confident so we don't we're
not saying kind of precisely that the
probability of the actual proportion is
95% but we're 95% confident that the
true proportion is between is between
33% and 55% that P is in this range over
here or another way and you'll see this
in a lot of surveys that have been done
people will say we did a survey we did a
survey and we got 43% 43% we'll vote for
number one and number one in that kid
this case is candidate B it for
candidate B candidate B and then the
other side since everyone else voted for
candidate
57% will vote for a and then they're
going to put a margin of error and
you'll see this in any survey that you
see on TV they'll put a margin margin of
error and the margin of error is just
another way of describing this
confidence interval and they'll say that
the margin of error in this case is 10
percent is 10 percent which means that
there's a 95% confidence interval if you
go plus or minus 10% from that value
right over there and I really want to
emphasize you can't say with certainty
that there is a 95% chance that the true
result will be within 10% of this
because we had to estimate the standard
deviation
of the sampling mean but I just wanted
but this is the best measure we can with
the information you have if you're going
to do a survey of 100 people this is the
best kind of confidence that we can get
and this number is actually fairly big
so if you were to look at this you would
say you know roughly there's a 95%
chance that the true value of this
number is between 33 and 53 percent so
there's actually still a chance that
candidate B can win even though only 43
percent of your hundred are going to
vote for them if you wanted to make if
you want to make a little bit more
precise you want it you would want to
take more samples you can imagine if you
instead of taking a hundred samples
instead of n being a hundred if you made
any Qin then you would take this number
over here you take this number here and
divided by the square root of a thousand
instead of the square root of 100 so you
you know you'd be dividing by 33 or
whatever and so then your margin of the
number the size of the standard
deviation of your of your sampling
distribution will go down and so the
distance of two standard deviations will
be a smaller number and so then you will
have a smaller margin of error and maybe
you want to get the smaller margin area
the margins are small enough so that you
can figure out decisively who's going to
win the election